What if I told you that you've been
ignoring the most important call of your
life? That nagging feeling pulling you
towards something greater isn't random.
It's your destiny knocking. Every hero's
journey begins with a call. That moment
when ordinary life is interrupted by
something
extraordinary. But here's the truth
about thresholds. They're terrifying.
Your brain floods you with doubt and
fear. That's not a sign you're on the
wrong path. It's confirmation you're
finally on the right one. The difference
between those who transform and those
who remain stagnant is simple. Heroes
answer the call. We expect
transformation to feel good. But real
change involves loss and moments of
complete disorientation as you shed who
you used to be. Your inmost cave is
where your greatest treasure and deepest
fear reside together. Everything you
want most exists on the other side of
that fear. The most powerful moment in
any hero's journey is realizing it never
ends. But now you know something
essential. You have everything you need
to meet each new challenge. You are the
chosen one. Not because you're special,
but because everyone is. And the moment
you embrace that truth is when your real
journey begins.